The original "John Wick" has stood the test of
time as one of the more perfect modern action
movies. We've loved the premise since the first
time we heard it — man loses wife, man gets dog,
mobster kills dog, and man violently
gets his revenge on about ninety people.
The dog is avenged. A new dog is
acquired. All is right in the world.
"That's crazy sh-t, man."
But then, the world expanded. "John Wick: Chapter
2" came along, furthering the story of the
vengeful assassin and ladling out more lore about
the circle of killers in which he used to run.
"Maybe," the film posits, "some people get
upset when their relatives get stomped,
the same way that John Wick got
upset about his stomped-up dog."
Commence to more killing as John Wick fights
to survive the wave of shooters coming for him.
John and his new dog go on the run,
with danger around every corner.
Common gets a knife stuck in his
torso! John Wick does Joker's trick!
"Ta-da!"
Truly, it doesn't get any better than
this… or so we thought. And then…
"I'm thinkin' I'm back!"
This is the world that viewers can expect
to walk into if they flip on "John Wick:
Chapter 3 — Parabellum," the threequel that's
making waves on Netflix in certain International
markets right this minute. Sorry Americans,
not on your Netflix, only other regions.
It's a world of action. A world of adventure.
A world where the exchange rate on giant gold
coins remains bamboozlingly inconsistent.
Like, you can use one to buy a gun,
but you can also use one to buy a gin and
tonic? Whatever, that's not the point.
The movie picks up right where Chapter 2 left off,
so John Wick has a $14 million bounty on his
head. With an hour to leave the city and a
promise that he'll stomp any assassins that try
to take him out, our hero makes a hasty escape,
taking a break to fight some guys in an
antique warehouse to keep things interesting.
A jetsetting adventure is well underway,
and Wick takes off for Casablanca,
searching for a higher-up from the High Table
— basically, he wants to speak to a manager.
"I'd like to see the manager." "Of course."
Meanwhile, in New York,
change is the only constant,
and Wick's old buddies The Bowery King and Winston
are being forced out of their positions of power
on account of their having helped the protagonist.
There's plenty of blood, lots of fights, a
horse-versus-motorcycle battle in heavy traffic,
and so on. Most importantly, thanks to
the addition of Halle Berry's Sofia,
the dogs finally get a chance to
do some stomping of their own.
"Good to see you, too."
"I should shoot you in the head right now."
"I know."
Basically, if you're looking for a good time
at the movies and don't mind watching your hero
slaughtering roughly a hundred goons, "John Wick:
Chapter 3 — Parabellum" might just be your jam.
"I gotta tell you, I've been looking
forward to meeting you for a long time."
It is a rare and beautiful thing to find a movie
about a guy who's great at shooting people that
gets near-uniformly glowing reviews. "John Wick:
Chapter 3 — Parabellum" is that beautiful thing.
With a Certified Fresh critics' rating of 89%
on Rotten Tomatoes, the third movie in the saga
of John Wick is neck-and-neck with "Chapter 2"
for the title of Best Reviewed Film in the
Franchise. The Chicago Tribune called it
"the best of the three so far." The Guardian
extolled, quote, "fight sequences so balletic
you might forget you're watching violence –
until Reeves sinks a knife into a man's eye."
Peter Travers of Rolling Stone, in a 4.5 out of
5 star review, told hesitant potential viewers,
"You can wait around and hope for a bigger,
badder burst of action fireworks than 'John
Wick 3,' but you'd be kidding yourself."
All in all, "John Wick: Chapter 3" is everything
that fans could hope for in a blockbuster action
sequel. It offers the same flavor of violence
being doled out in the first two films,
with a considered bump in intensity and
ambition from series director Chad Stahelski.
The worst thing you can say about the
picture is that it ends with more of
a question mark than a period, but
like everything else about the movie,
that's a choreographed move — "John Wick:
Chapter 4" is slated to hit theaters in 2022.
"Nice to meet you, Mr. Wick."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.